Hello, class. Dr.
Jonathan Geisler here.
So today I'm going
to be talking to you
about the orbit and the
extraocular muscles.
And this lecture is
going to be distributed
among four videos.
So this is the first
one. So let's go
ahead and get started.
Okay. So there's going
to be quite a few
session or objectives
for these sessions.
But let's go ahead
and start with
the one that we're
going to be covering
in this first of four
videos. And so by
the end of the
session, you should be
able to infer what
structures can be
affected by blowout
fractures of the orbit.
In terms of sort
of contents for
this first video,
this part one,
we're going to
be talking about
orbit boundaries
and its contents.
So here we're looking at
an axial MRI of the head.
You can see the nose
here. Here's the
brain right there in
the cranial cavity.
These are the
ethmoidal sinuses,
bright white here.
These are the
eyes. And then this
here is the orbit.
You might be able
to tell that this is
a T2-weighted MRI
by the fact that the
cerebral spinal fluid
is bright white.
What I want to draw
your attention to here
is how bright it is in
the orbit. And that's
basically telling us
that the orbit has
a lot of adipose tissue.
This is one of those
interesting anatomical
facts that's not
really often apparent
when you look at a kind
of schematic image in
an anatomy textbook,
but it's important
because this adipose
tissue essentially
behaves sort of like a
fluid. So if there is
pressure on the orbit,
fluids are non
-compressible. So this
fat is non-compressible,
and if there's
enough pressure,
that adipose tissue
is going to want to
go somewhere else,
and that can potentially
cause a trauma
in the orbit and
surrounding tissues.
So let's talk about
the boundaries of
the orbit and one way
to sort of envision
it is like a
pyramid with an apex
here in the posterior
end of the orbit
and then four sides,
a superior side
also called the
roof, a medial side,
an inferior side or
floor, and a lateral
side. in terms of
the bones that make
up these different
sides, the roof is
predominantly formed
by the frontal bone.
Then the lateral
side here is formed
by this pink bone,
the sphenoid bone.
It's divided into
two parts. So the
greater wing of the
sphenoid makes up
most of the lateral
side of the orbit.
This part here called
the lesser wing
of the sphenoid
contributes a little
part here to the
roof of the orbit.
And this bone
here, the zygomatic
bone, helps form
that lateral side
of the orbit. The
maxilla in gray
forms most of the
floor of the orbit.
And then the medial
side of the orbit has
contributions from
the frontal, but is
predominantly formed
here by this plate of
the ethmoid, and also
a contribution here
from this bone here,
which is the lacrimal.
Now, in addition to these
bones, which are
fairly rigid,
the floor of the orbit,
right, or this orbital
pyramid here, is
sealed up by this tough
fibrous membrane called
the orbital septum.
And the reason that's
important is pretty
much all sides of the
orbit are fairly rigid.
So, for example, if
there was bleeding
inside the orbit, such
like maybe a patient
arrives in the ER after
being in an automobile
accident, you can
have a situation
develop in the orbit,
much like a compartment
syndrome in the limb.
So a lot of pressure
can build up very
quickly. So you might
choose to cut this
medial or lateral
palpebral ligament to
let some of the blood
out and relieve the
pressure in the orbit.
here we're looking
at a coronal ct of
the head this is where
the anterior cranial
cavity and the
brain is right here
got one orbit the
other here's the oral
cavity with the teeth
as you know by now
black essentially
indicates air so these
are the paranasal
sinuses that are on
either side of the
nasal cavities here.
And what I want to
draw your attention
to is how incredibly
thin is the bone
that is separating
the medial wall of
the orbit from the
ethmoidal sinuses
and the floor
of the orbit
from the
maxillary sinuses.
And so as I was talking
before, if there's
any pressure to the
orbit, say maybe this
individual falls
and there's a lot of
pressure on the eye.
That adipose tissue,
remember, is not going
to be very compressible,
so it's going to
want to go somewhere.
It might break
through this thin bone
here, and in fact,
you can see right here
some of the contents
of the orbit are
pushing into this
ethmoidal sinus here.
Also, they may go into
the maxillary sinus,
and so it's not just
adipose tissue that
would do this, but
potentially some of the
extraocular muscles, which
we'll be talking about
in a minute, could
get trapped in there.
You could have also
some of the nerves and
artery of the eye get
damaged or cut by these
fractures. So
whenever you have
contents of the
orbit going into one
of these adjacent
paranasal sinuses,
that's called a
blowout fracture.
So for the rest of
this video, I'm going
to focus on the basic
anatomy, these extraocular
muscles. So we're
going to start with
this one here called
the levator palpebrae
superioris. The name
kind of tells you
what it does levator
elevates the superior
eyelid in terms of its
origin it's from the
lesser wing of the
sphenoid and it starts
on that superior
tarsus the upper eyelid
and it also contains
some smooth muscle
fibers this view here
shows if you had removed
the brain or
approaching the orbit
superiorly break through
and remove that roof
of the orbit you can
see this first muscle
here is the levator
palpebrae superioris.
Next, we have four
****** muscles.
There's a superior,
inferior, and medial
and lateral ******.
All of these muscles
attach from this structure
here in the posterior
side of the orbit,
which is called the
common tendinus ring.
That common tendinus
ring is also attached
to the lesser wing
of the sphenoid. These
muscles essentially
go anteriorly, and
they're going to attach
to the sclera just
posterior to the cornea.
Then we have two
oblique muscles. So
first we have the
superior oblique.
That too is going to
originate from the
lesser wing of the
sphenoid. It's going
to go anteriorly, pass
through this little
muscular sling
called the trochlea,
which redirects the
muscle fibers posterior
laterally and then
it attaches on the
sclera on the superior
side of the eye.
The inferior oblique
has its origin here
on the medial side
of the orbit passes
laterally and a
little posteriorly to
attach to the inferior
side of the eye a
little deep here to
the lateral ******.
Now in terms of the
innervations of the
muscles one way to
remember is by this kind
of sort of fake
chemical formula here,
SO4LR6A03. So SO stands
for superior oblique.
The 4 indicates it's
innervated by the
fourth cranial nerve.
LR stands for lateral
******. The 6 indicates
it's innervated by
the sixth cranial
nerve. AO stands for all
others. And 3 is the
third cranial nerve.
these cranial nerves
also have other names
so the fourth is also
called the trochlear
nerve and one other
way to sort of
remember this is that
you remember the superior
oblique passed through
that trochlea that
little muscular that
little sling and so
another name for the
fourth cranial nerve
is the trochlear
nerve then the lateral
****** attaches to the
lateral side of the
eye. When it contracts,
it's going to
abduct the eye. And so
another name for the
sixth cranial nerve
is the abducens nerve.
And finally, just
going back to the
superior tarsal muscle
that's kind of embedded
or part of that
levator palpebrae
superioris, it's
innervated by post
-ganglionic sympathetics
whose cell bodies
reside in the superior
cervical ganglion.
Okay, so that's the
end of this first
of four videos. Next,
we'll be talking
about simple
movements of the eye,
and I look forward
to seeing you then.
Okay, so this
objective we covered
in the first four
videos. In this
video, by the end
of it, you should be
able to differentiate
actions and
functions of the
extraocular muscles.
and in terms of content
we're really going
to focus on the simple
movements of the eye
in this video okay so
let's talk a little
bit about terminology
and actions of the
eyeball so here we have a
patient looking straight
at us um kind of
facing us so this would
be called primary
position if the eye looks
upward that would be
called elevation eye
looking downward
that's depression. Eye
looking over towards
the nose or the medial
side, that's adduction.
Eye looking over towards
the lateral side,
that would be called
abduction. If the eye
is rotating this way,
that's called extortion.
And the eye rotating
this way, that would
be called intorsion.
Now, in terms of this
differentiating action
and function of the
extraocular muscles,
action is what a
muscle would do in
isolation whereas a
muscle's function is how
it actually contributes
to a particular
motion now sometimes
these are the same an
example of one of the
muscles from the first
video was the levator
palpebrae superioris
its only antagonist
is gravity so if that
muscle contracts its
action and function
are the same the
superior eyelid elevates
here we have sort of
a schematic image of
the head in superior
view sort of like what
we might see in an
axial ct or mri and all
of here are the two
orbits and as you remember
their boundaries are
primarily made up of
bone this blue line
indicates the axis of
the orbit it's not
going straight anterior
posteriorly it's at sort
of an angle and it's
fixed it doesn't
change by contrast the
axis of the eyeball varies.
Here it's in primary
position looking
forward, but of course
the eye can look many
different directions.
And the fact that these
two are often offset
causes a lot of
complexity in
understanding the functions
of the extraocular
muscles. In this
video, we're
going to start with
the simple cases.
So here we have
an eye in primary
position, looking
straight forward,
if we contract
the lateral
******, the eye is
going to abduct.
Now the optical
axis and the orbital
axis are aligned.
If we contract the
superior ******,
the eye elevates.
If we then contract
the inferior ******,
the abducted
eye depresses.
now again starting in
primary position if
we contract the medial
****** the eye is
going to adduct
now notice here the
superior oblique here
passing through that
trochlea because it
goes through that and
the fibers then go
posterior laterally
essentially this muscle
is pulling from the
front of the eye this
is different than
what we saw with the
****** muscles that
all attached to that
common tendinous ring.
So if the superior
oblique contracts,
then the adducted eye
is going to depress.
Then if we can
kind of see through
the eye here to
see the inferior
oblique attaching on
its inferior side,
if the inferior
oblique contracts,
then the eye elevates.
So just to summarize
these simple cases,
the superior ******
is a strong elevator
of the already A
-B ducted eyeball.
By contrast, the
inferior ******
is a strong depressor of
the already A-B
ducted eyeball.
The inferior oblique
is a strong elevator
of the already A
-deducted eye, and
the superior
oblique is a strong
depressor of the
already A-deducted eye.
so that's the end
of this second video
we'll next deal with
complex movements of the
eye i look forward to
seeing you then okay
so these first two
objectives we covered
in the first and
second videos here here
in the third by the
end of this session
you should be able
to describe how extra
ocular muscles work
in pairs to induce or
avoid torsion you
should also be able to
describe how the extra
ocular muscles work in
pairs to move the eye
in primary position
and we can kind
of summarize
this video really
focused on the
complex movements
of the eye
so I'm going to spend
some time going over
this particular image
here you'll find
something like this in
your textbook and it's
pretty much in most
anatomical textbooks
when they talk about
the extraocular muscles
in some ways this
image is very confusing
but because it sort
of can be confused
with another image
that really gets to how
can you identify where
a particular lesion
is on a nerve that
innervates a muscle of
the eye we need to spend
some time going over
it first thing to
focus on is this image
is looking at actions
not function right so
this is if one single
extraocular muscle
is going to contract
that is not typically
the case with a lot of
movements of the eye.
So this is sort of a
unique situation here
when we're looking at
this particular image.
The other key thing,
and this is probably
the most important,
is this only applies
to the eye in primary
position. That means
the patient's looking
straight ahead.
The minute the eye
deviates from primary
position, it's going to
get more complicated,
a little bit different
than what this
particular image
portrays. So just to
go through here, these
letters here, I-O-L
-R-S-O, These all
refer to our different
muscles, superior
******, medial ******,
inferior ******.
And then what you'll
notice here, these
kind of larger arrows
and smaller arrows.
So if we start
with things that
sort of make sense
here, like medial
******, it's a fairly
straightforward
movement. It contracts,
and the eye is going
to be adducted.
Similar with lateral
******, that muscle
contracts. The
eye is going to be
abducted. But then we
see things a little
more confusing here
with like superior
****** here. We see
this angled elevation,
but also this other
little line here.
What's actually happening
here is that the
eye is essentially a
sphere. So whenever
you pull on a ball,
it basically moves
much like a wheel with
an axis of rotation.
So the actual
movement is a curved
line or an arc. And
what they've done
here is split that
curved arc movement
into a series of
orthogonal vectors.
I find that somewhat
confusing, and so
I'm going to spend
some time showing
some other images that
I think are really
going to make a lot
more sense to you.
So where these complex
movements come from
this fact that the axis
of the orbit, which
is fixed, is often
at an angle from the
axis of the eyeball.
And whenever that
happens, if one muscle
is going to contract,
in all likelihood,
there's going to be some
torsion that's going
to also accompany
either the elevation
or the depression. Now,
there are cases
where we want to have
torsion. If we're tilting
our head to one side
or the other, we
want a little bit of
intorsion or extorsion
to maintain a level gaze.
But more often than
not, torsion is
something to avoid. And
so to avoid the torsion
when the axis of the
eyeball and the axis
of the orbit are not
in line, basically
multiple muscles have
to contract at once.
So let me walk through
this image here. It's
a schematic image of
kind of the superior
view of the head. You
can see the nose here.
And this red arrow on
this side is basically
referring to the
vector of movement for
the inferior and superior
******, right? So
they're going to pull
either on the superior
or inferior side of
the sclera like this,
back towards the posterior
or the apex of the
orbit. So the axis of
rotation is just 90
degrees to the
direction of the muscle
pulling, right? So
essentially, if we project
this axis of rotation
out, it would appear
right here on the medial
corner of the eye. So
this is for inferior
and superior ******.
Then if we go on
the other eye,
this vector here
is really showing
kind of the way
that both the
inferior and superior
oblique pull.
And so, again, the
axis of rotation is
90 degrees to that. If
we project that out,
that comes out in
the lateral corner
of the eye. Now, of
course, there's inferior
and superior ******
on both orbits as
well as inferior and
superior oblique.
So this image here
would just show the axis
of rotation of all
these muscles on both
eyes. Again, so here we
have axis of rotation
of superior and inferior
******, and here
we would have superior
and inferior oblique.
Now, if we have
the patient looking
straight at us in
primary position,
here is the axis
of rotation of the
superior ****** and
inferior ******.
and here in that
lateral corner is the
axis of rotation
of the superior
oblique and inferior
oblique. So let's
say this patient
is going to elevate
their eye starting
in primary position.
So if they were
just to contract the
superior ******,
you would get this
arc of movement,
which is essentially
going around this
axis of rotation
for the superior
and inferior ******.
If they also at the
same time, right,
or let's just say
they just contract the
inferior oblique, it too
will go around its axis
of rotation right here.
But if they contract
both of these muscles
at the same time,
the torsion effects are
going to cancel out.
You're going to get
smooth elevation.
In this case, the
superior ****** is doing
intorsion, inferior
obliques doing extorsion,
and those cancel out
smooth elevation.
So we just talked a
little bit about primary
position. And so one
way to think about
that is in primary
position, roughly you got
kind of 50-50 in terms
of the contraction of
the superior ******
and inferior oblique.
and this would be
elevation without any
sort of torsion. So
this little schematic
image, you have more
contraction, less
contraction. Here's the
abeducted eye. Here's
primary position.
Here's the adeducted
eye. If you remember
from the last video,
if you have the abeducted
eye, pretty much
the only thing you
need to do to elevate
the eye without any
sort of torsion is
contract superior
******. So all superior
******, no inferior
oblique. By contrast
with the adeducted
eye, if you remember,
You just need to
contract the inferior
oblique, nothing
else, and you'll
get elevation without
torsion. So you
can imagine at this
point right here,
you might need
about, you know, 75%
superior ******, 25
% inferior obliques.
And we would see the same
thing on the other eye.
What about depression?
So if the patient
wants to press their
eye, they're going to
do inferior ******,
right? it would rotate
around this axis
superior oblique would
rotate around this axis
this would be intorsion
this would be extorsion
but essentially
their torsion effects
are going to cancel
out and you're going to
get smooth depression
now let's say if
we wanted torsion
without any elevation or
depression so both the
superior ****** and
the superior oblique
attached to the superior
side of the eye.
So you can see if
these muscle bellies
shorten, the eye is
just going to rotate
like this. Of course,
it's not going
to go all the way
around, be more subtle,
but this would be
the direction of
rotation. This is
intorsion. Remember the
superior ******, that
causes elevation,
intorsion.
Superior oblique
causes depression and
intorsion. So in
this case, if you
contract both of
these muscles the
elevation and the
depression will cancel
out and you'll get
smooth intorsion.
Then looking at depression
and extortion and
and how this relates
to the canceling out
with elevation here if
we contract both the
inferior ****** and the
inferior oblique and
these muscle bellies
are going to shorten.
The eye would rotate
in this direction.
That's extorsion.
The elevation of the
inferior oblique is
going to cancel out with
the depression of
the inferior ******,
and you're going to
get smooth extorsion.
Okay, so this is the end
of this particular video.
Next, we're really
going to kind of go to
the next step which
is sort of applying
this information to
understanding what's
affecting a particular
patient so that'll
be nerve lesions and
extraocular muscles
i look forward to
seeing you then
okay so in
terms of session
objectives we've
covered in these
four in the previous
three videos
now in this video
which is kind of more
clinically relevant
one we're going to
at the end of it you
should be able to
predict lesions and
nerves of the orbit
based on test of
extraocular muscles.
We're going to focus
on really nerve
lesions here, but in
reality, at least with
the information I'm
going to be providing
to you, it would
be difficult to
tell whether the problem
is with a particular
nerve or the muscle
it innervates.
Okay, so the
key thing with
this particular
image here,
and it might look
familiar to you, right? We
have a series of
extraocular muscles, right?
Inferior oblique,
medial ******, and we
have the eye here. You
might say, oh, this
looks familiar to me.
I've seen this before
because it looks a lot
like a chart that I
showed at the beginning
of the previous video.
And students often
confuse the two, but
this is very, very
different. So let me
just go back to review.
That previous image
was looking at or
trying to describe
the actions of the
extraocular muscles with
the eye in primary
position. It's somewhat
theoretical. It's
basically saying if
your patient's looking
ahead, you could
somehow tell them just,
you know, contract
the superior ******,
what would the eye
do when it starts
in primary position?
This image is something
very different.
So this is much more
clinically relevant.
And basically what
it's saying is this
is how you want the
patient to move their
eye try to figure out
where a particular
problem is or at
least to test the
function of all their
extraocular muscles
and so that previous
schematic diagram
was all about primary
position this one
is not basically what
you want to do is
get the patient out
of primary position
because you remember
primary position
is complicated. You
need two muscles to
create intorsion,
two muscles to create
extorsion, two to
elevate, two to depress
the eye. And so if you
see a problem there,
it's hard to know
which of the muscles
or which of the nerves
that are innervating
those muscles is not
working properly.
So what you want to do
with your patient is
get them to move the
eye out of primary
position, and then you
have a reasonable shot
of figuring out what
the problem is. So
you're going to ask
the patient to kind of
create this H pattern
by either following
your finger or maybe
a flashlight and then
seeing if the patient can
do all these movements.
So let's say we
start with primary
position, but now we
want to get the eye out
of primary position.
We ask the patient to
adduct the eye. They
can do that. That
tells us medial ******
is working well.
Then you want to depress
the adducted eye.
Check superior
oblique's working well.
Elevate the adducted
eye. Inferior
oblique is
working well. And
go back to kind
of a level gaze,
abeduct the eye, lateral
****** is working, check.
Depress the
abeducted eye,
inferior ******
is working, check.
Elevate the abeducted
eye, superior ******
is working, check.
So essentially what
we're doing here is
we're moving the eye
to these extreme
corners where we're sort
of forcing function
to equal action and
in a place where
really only one single
muscle is causing the
observed movement.
So let's apply
this kind of
thinking to a
couple patients.
So here, let's say
we have this patient
present here. First
thing you notice is this
eye is closed, right?
We call this ptosis.
And so this is our first
hint of what's
going on here.
If you remember,
there are some smooth
muscle fibers in the
levator palpebrae
superioris. superior
auras that are being
innervated by a sympathetic
to a cell body or
in that superior cervical
ganglion. So this
is a first hint that
the ocular motor
nerve is not working
properly because those
nerve fibers travel
in the ocular motor
nerve. Now, if we
force open that eyelid,
ask the patient to
look straight ahead,
we see this eye is
working fine. This
one definitely not,
and we kind of refer
to this condition
as down and out. So
I haven't talked much
about antagonists
at this point, but
that's really what's
going on here. So
if the ocular motor
nerve in its entirety
is knocked out,
right, superior
****** not
working, inferior
oblique not working,
medial ******
not working,
inferior ******
not working.
So the only things
left, right,
are going to be
the lateral ******,
which is innervated
by the abducens
nerve, and the
superior oblique, which
is innervated by
the trochlear nerve.
Lateral ****** is going
to be able to abduct
the eye because
there's no antagonist.
The medial ****** is
not working, so that's
the out part. And
then the superior
oblique is going to
depress the eye because
the superior ******
and inferior oblique
are not working, so
that's the down part.
Now, one other thing
to remember about the
ocular motor nerve,
this is sort of the
condition where the
entire nerve has a
lesion on, it's not
working. But do remember
that the acromotor
nerve splits into a
superior and an inferior
division. Do superior
division innervates
the levator palpebrae
superioris and the
superior ******,
whereas the inferior
division is going to
innervate the inferior
oblique medial ******
and inferior ******.
So you could also
have some slight
differences in how a
patient presents,
depending on whether that
lesion's on the
superior division or the
inferior division of
the oculomotor nerve.
So now we're looking
at probably the hardest
case to kind of wrap
your mind around.
So here, you know,
we have a patient,
they're tilting their
head to one side to
maintain that level
gaze. We want the
eye to undergo smooth
torsion without
elevation or depression.
And the eyes would
do different kind
of opposite types of
torsion, right? So
here we have the left
eye, it's undergoing
intorsion, and then
the other eye is
undergoing extorsion.
Everything looks fine,
right? Gaze
straight ahead.
But now when we have
the patient tilt
their head to the other
side, right, we've
flipped the required
torsion for each
eye. So now this eye
is undergoing extorsion
and this one's
undergoing intorsion.
This eye still looks
fine, looking straight
at us. But here I
think you can see that
this eye sort of deviated
a little bit to go
up. So what's happening
here? To create
intorsion, to smooth
intorsion, what you want is
both muscles that
attach to the superior
side of the eye, that's
the superior oblique
and the superior ******
to contract at the
same time. They both
cause intorsion. Remember,
the superior ******
is going to cause
elevation of the eye if
it acts alone, and the
superior oblique will
cause depression of
the eye if it acts
alone. So that elevation
of depression should
cancel out and we get
smooth intorsion. When
we see the eye elevating
here, that's telling
us that the antagonist
of the superior
****** is not working.
So now what we're seeing
is only the action
of the superior ******,
which is the cause
and torsion of the eye,
but also elevation.
And so that tells
us really that that
antagonist is
superior oblique or
the nerve that
innervates that the
trochlear nerve is
not working properly.
And so this is
sort of called the
Bischowski sign. And
basically whenever the
head is tilted to
the affected side,
you're going to see
this slight elevation
of the eye. We could
further test this,
right, by having the
patient look straight
ahead, not tilt
their head, do that
H pattern, and we
would predict that
they could not depress
the adducted eye.
Okay, so this is our
summary slide from all
four videos. Let's just
kind of review what
you should be able
to do at this point
after watching these
videos. So remember
contents of the orbiter,
not compressible.
There's a lot of either
either there's a fluid
in the eye itself or
the adipose tissue
essentially acts as a fluid.
It's not compressible.
So if there's a
lot of pressure in
the eye that's going
to require defects in
the base or the walls
of the orbit and you
could very possibly
get a blowout fracture.
Remember action and
function often mean very
different things for
extraocular muscles.
The torsion in the
eye occurs when the
optic axis is at an
angle to the axis of
the orbit. And that
happens quite a bit
because remember
the most common is
primary position
looking straight ahead.
Now torsion is not
always a bad thing.
You want to have
that intorsion or
extorsion when you're
tilting your head.
Action and function
are usually described
relative to primary position
so if you're looking
in a textbook trying
to see what's the
the action or the
function of a particular
extraocular muscle that's
in primary position
but remember stating
the obvious you can look
many different ways
and in those different
orientations particular
extra ocular muscle
is going to have a
different function and then
finally extraocular
muscle function is
tested by having the
patient not look in primary
position so you want to
get it out of complex
areas and move it
to those simple more
extreme corners of the
eye okay so that's the
end of this video if
you have any questions
about the orbiter
extraocular muscles please
make sure to reach out
to me see you again